aktuell auf bild.de oder Focus online zu
lesen für Anke Engelke sind soziale
Netzwerke Dreck jetzt tut Ina Müller in
der Online Talkshow klicksum.de in
selbehorn schreibt doch was ihr wollt
ihr Arschlöcher egal ob Facebook Twitter
oder Youtube sie stören die oft
hämischen Kommentare in den sozialen
Netzwerken ich sehe einfach nur wenn ich
durchs Internet stöber dass jeder jeder
heutzutage die Möglichkeit hat sich
verbal da ich muss wirklich sagen
auszugüllen das ist so ein sehr
ländlicher Begriff das stört mich
besonders wenn es um die eigene Karriere
geht ist die Künstlerin empfindlich wenn
Irin Kritiker über Ina Müller schreibt
die ist so und so dass dann direkt
wieder da 1000 Leute drunter schreiben
ja wir finden auch Ina Müller geht zum
Friseur lässt sich die Haare kurz
schneiden ein Deutschland ist
erschüttert also sagte mir eben gerade
ein Journalist mit dem ich telefoniert
hat unsere Redaktion war erschüttert
ohon dabei ist Müller gar nicht so Nerv
Stk wie sie in ihrer eigenen Sendung
erscheint jeden Tag wirst du
bewertet was war gut was war schlecht
wie war die Quote wie war sie da wie war
sie hier ich habe auch nur einen mäßig
breiten Rücken wo das alles rauf geheht
oder mäßig viel Haut auf die das alles
geht ich kann das nicht alles so
wegstecken ich bin da empfindlich
empfindlich dürfen allerdings nicht ihre
Exfreunde sein Ina Müller teilt nämlich
selbst gerne aus in ihrem neuen Album
das wä dein Lied gewesen bekommt jeder
ihrer exlava sein Fett weg also das wäre
de nie gewesen hat lange gedauert bis
das fertig war weil ich war lange auf
der Suche nach der absolut ultimativsten
Beleidigung was man jemandem sagen kann
man kann ja sagen Arschloch das verhalt
relativ schnell und ist auch nicht so
individuell aber wenn man sagt weißt du
was ich wollte dir Lied schreiben aber
es geht gar nicht du reichst nicht mal
für zweieinhalb Zeilen dann ist das ganz
böse also ich ich mich könnte man damit
sehr treffen glaube ich ab sofort
käuflich Ina Müller beschimpft ihre
Exfreunde musikalisch mal sehen ob die
exlover auf Facebook und Twitter
zurückstenkn